[Musica]
buonasera a tutti e buona festa a tutte
le donne
quando ero molto piccolo ho sempre
trovato le mura di casa piuttosto
strette e ho capito molto presto che con
la musica attraverso la musica avrei
potuto varcare quel quelle mura e
viaggiare
qualche anno dopo è successo davvero
perché durante l'adolescenza
ho deciso di scappare di casa e di fare
l'esperienza del musicista di strada per
un paio di mesi diciamo vivevo delle
monetine che la gente buttava nel nella
custodia del mio strumento è stata
un'esperienza bellissima era in irlanda
il resto street che la strada almeno
erano i tempi la strada più famosa per i
musicisti di strada però la cosa che mi
interessa molto dirvi è questa qualcosa
di molto interessante sempre grazie alla
magia della musica che era avvenuta poco
prima quando appunto ero così piccolo
prima ancora di uscire fisicamente di
casa e andare a scoprire il mondo e
questo è il discorso che ho scoperto che
era possibile abbattere le mura di casa
e viaggiare con la mente e con il cuore
con l'anima grazie alla musica perché
questa la musica ci consente di fare e
questo aspetto in realtà è proprio non
solo della musica ma di qualcosa di cui
vorrei parlarvi stasera e cioè dei sogni
del sogno il sogno è forse la cosa più
importante che esiste nelle nostre vite
e spesso pensiamo al sogno come qualcosa
di impalpabile di di non concreto di
astratto quando in realtà molto spesso è
una delle cose più concrete che ci possa
essere nella vita di una persona
questo perché un sogno per essere tale
qualcosa che si si costruisce giorno per
giorno non è qualcosa che quasi non
esiste o non esiste è improvvisamente si
agguanta così senza sport idee diventa
realtà
in realtà appunto scusate il gioco di
parole il sogno quello vero può essere
qualcosa che diventa la realtà e questo
avviene come dicevo il giorno per giorno
con un lavoro quotidiano con una visione
con un'idea e con un lavoro instancabile
con coraggio e la prima cosa da fare è
come in un viaggio uscire dalla propria
con forza
cioè dal proprio dalla zona in cui ci
sentiamo a nostro agio e osare mettersi
in viaggio partire spesso partire con un
progetto con qualsiasi cosa è la cosa
più difficile
tra l'altro io ho qualche notte in
bianco per preparare la mia partenza
a pochi minuti e sa di cosa parlo ma
anche nella vita spesso a partire la
cosa più difficile perché significa
anche vincere le proprie paure significa
vincere quindi noi stessi le paure sono
effettivamente qualcosa che ci può
bloccare
ma anche va detto se non esistessero non
esisterebbe il coraggio e proprio con il
coraggio dobbiamo cercare di inseguire
questi nostri sogni e perché questo
avvenga in realtà ci sono un paio di
cose che sono molto importanti da dire
la prima della appena detto è avere il
coraggio di fare il primo passo partire
uscire da questa confort son
la seconda è quella di avere una grande
determinazione ovviamente di non neanche
nei momenti più bui
mai mai mai fermarsi mai farsi prendere
dallo scoramento e diciamo e questo è
possibile chiaramente solo e soltanto
con una grande forza di volontà tutte le
cose più belle come esseri umani che
sono state create nei più diversi mondi
da quelli artistici a quelli tecnologici
creativi sono state tutto è possibile
con una grande forza di determinazione
quello che a me piace chiamare un
desiderio feroce questo desiderio feroce
è lo stesso come immagine che potrebbe
diciamo prendere quello che fa persino a
una piantina una esile piantina bucare
l'asfalto è fare sì breccia attraverso
il cemento questa è una forza che ha la
natura è che anche dentro di noi e
questa stessa forza è quella appunto
come dicevo che ci porta piano piano
quando abbiamo una visione quando
abbiamo un'idea di qualcosa in questo
senso un sogno qualcosa che ancora non
c'è ma potrebbe esserci è questo il
punto cioè noi alla fine con quel lavoro
piccolo quotidiano quasi impercettibile
ci troviamo nel tempo a spostare piano
piano il limite di quello che è
possibile
e guardando bene quello che è possibile
in quel momento realmente quindi alla
fine se ci pensate bene stiamo
semplicemente costruendo questo sogno
ora ci sono casi meravigliosi e
anche motti stupendi o uno dei moti che
amo di più su quello di enzo ferrari che
diceva uno degli italiani più celebri
forse più celebri sarebbero all'estero
che diceva se lo puoi sognare lo puoi
fare
ho scoperto poi che era lo stesso
identico moto che aveva walt disney e
non credo sia un caso anche perché hanno
vite storie diverse ma proprio perché
condividevano la stessa filosofia lo
stesso visione del mondo e nel loro caso
la loro stessa lista nera la più
evidente dimostrazione e questa forza di
volontà trasforma i nostri limiti
gli ostacoli che troviamo durante le
nostre giornate la nostra vita nel
nostro cercare di fare qualcosa di buono
trasforma questi stessi limiti le
approcciamo nel modo giusto in
opportunità per andare oltre per
trasformare quello che è un problema in
qualcosa che ci fa pensare fuori dagli
schemi ci fa trovare soluzioni che
altrimenti magari non avremmo nemmeno
potuto pensare quindi non è come si dice
tutto il mare non è non tutto il male
vien per nuocere non si dice scusate
questo è il punto e quindi mi viene in
mente non so uno dei più grandi
chitarristi mai esistiti che ha
sconvolto innovato tantissimo nel mondo
del mio strumento e django reinhardt che
durante un incidente purtroppo ebbe
infortunato alla mano e si trova a dover
suonare con soltanto due dita della mano
sinistra è una grandissima limitazione
eppure ha trovato un modo di suonare che
ha fatto veramente scuola oppure che ne
so in ambito automobilistico me viene in
mente nuvolari che magari trovandosi
persino priva della possibilità di usare
il volante per magari un ringraziamento
era in grado di finire la gara e
vincerla con una chiave inglese usandola
come come volante fino a farlo diventare
una leggenda vera e propria ma il punto
è proprio questo il coraggio di partire
e di osare e di non fermarsi ora nel mio
piccolissimo nel mio piccolissimo la mia
piccolissima storia diciamo la prima
sfida in questo percorso vinta o se
preferite il primo piccolo sogno
realizzato si chiama octopus octopus è
un sistema che è stato brevettato
elettro acustico in realtà è piuttosto
voluminoso tanto per cercare di darvi un
immagine pesa circa 230 chili come un
pianoforte a coda all'incirca
e non sarebbe nemmeno su questo
bellissimo palco ovviamente sono
felicissimo di essere qui e onorato ma
il punto è che questo sistema consente
un unico interprete di suonare più di
una chitarra anche contemporaneamente e
di estrapolare i suoni i modi molto
particolari manipolandoli in tempo reale
completamente dal vivo partendo dalla
vibrazione della corda
sapete diciamo questo un chitarrista
quando sono con la tecnica tradizionale
utilizza quattro dita con cui fa le note
e quelle altre con l'altra mano pizzica
realizza i suoni ma diciamo l'idea di
cercare di andare oltre a una
limitazione che è parte del nostro fare
musica come strumentisti e stata una
delle cause che ha fatto nascere questo
sistema è bene questo sistema come
dicevo consente un unico interprete di
suonare dal vivo anche più dello
strumento manipolando il suono anche con
non solo con le mani ma con gli altri
arti i piedi e persino alla bocca però
in modo forse migliore per darvi un'idea
di cosa si tratta e vederlo e quindi un
assaggino di 60 secondi con questo
famigerato octopus
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la musica è un'arte che si svolge nel
tempo la nostra tela è il tempo magari
la scultura la pittura hanno altri altre
materie prime da plasmare ma noi abbiamo
questo ed è quindi in effetti in questo
la rende forse anche un po impalpabile
come l'idea del sogno nell'inconscio
collettivo che abbiamo sempre quando
parliamo dei sogni ma allo stesso tempo
come nel mito di orfeo ed euridice noi
non possiamo mai fermarci per voltarci
indietro perché se ci fermassimo si
interromperebbe il tempo che è una parte
fondamentale della musica e si
romperebbe completamente la magia della
musica stessa
questo esattamente come nella vita non
possiamo mai fermarci dobbiamo sì vivere
presente ma cercando sempre di guardare
verso proiettati verso il nostro futuro
verso il futuro insomma quindi guardare
avanti guardare oltre è qualcosa di
molto importante nel mio mondo che
quello della musica e questo aspetto è
talmente importante che certe volte
rende possibile capire alcune cose del
fare musica
vi faccio un piccolo esempio stesso mi
capita di avere a che fare con studenti
che a un certo punto un bel giorno
devono interfacciarsi con il pubblico
cioè devono fare la loro
il loro primo concerto magari solista
davanti a un pubblico era la prima
performance è certamente un uscita da
quella con forza che li mette spesso in
grande apprensione hanno quindi molte
paure
cosa succede cosa succederà ma se
sbaglia se mi fermo accidenti eccetera
eccetera eccetera allora la cosa più
utile che io spesso riesco a fare con
loro e prenderli e portarli davanti una
finestra e dirgli metteteli e dr
cosa vedi cosa stai vedendo e quando gli
chiedi questa cosa loro rispondono di
solito vi guardano fuori e vedono
non so un paesaggio una strada un'auto e
mi descrivono quello che vedono allo
stesso tempo io poi li ferma gli dico
bene
ma tu hai visto qui sul vetro attraverso
cui tu guardi visto che qui c'è una
macchiolina e visto che la finestra è
fatta così da qua qua c'è un
imprecisione qui c'è una macchia una
cosa di questo tipo
ovviamente no perché il loro focus non
era lì era oltre stavano guardando fuori
da quella finestra
ora quando noi suoniamo in pubblico e
quindi si crea una comunicazione con chi
ci ascolta
se l'ascolta un ascolto ovvero succede
la stessa cosa si va oltre
nel senso che ogni musicista nessuno è
perfetto ci può essere l'imprecisione la
stecca l'errore problemi tecnici sono
problematico magari in un bellissimo non
importa
in realtà chi ascolta se ascolta
veramente cerca di raggiungere quell
emozione che sta dentro la musica che
sta dietro che forse proprio nell'anima
di chi suona e forse anche nell'anima di
chi ascolta e questa idea di andare
oltre e la stessa così importante nel
sogno perché appunto è lì che noi
dobbiamo cercare di abbattere le nostre
barriere che dicevamo sono proprio
questi limiti che abbiamo qualche volta
quando ci interfacciamo con loro e
quindi in questo stesso modo si potrebbe
dire è nato per esempio questo strumento
cioè da un'esigenza molto precisa
artistica ma anche sempre dalla ricerca
dal pensare fuori dagli schemi ed alla
ricerca di nuove possibilità
diciamo di superare qualche limitazione
questo strumento è diciamo un po
particolare
anche se esteticamente può assomigliare
ad altri strumenti esistono strumenti
con molte corde a partire già dal
periodo barocco nella sua esatta forma
che vedete qui è unico al mondo è una
star chitarra 49 corde e mi consente di
fare musica in un modo che per me è
ideale in un certo senso e io quindi
stasera in realtà ho in tasca già un
biglietto per l'aereo e prenderò il
treno appena finito questo speech salirò
su un aereo stanotte stessa per andare a
fare una serie di concerti per due mesi
negli stati uniti a fare alcune
masterclass nelle università e
in realtà anche con un progetto molto
preciso con un'idea molto precisa che
quella di portare quello che a me piace
chiamare l'innovatore mi piace molto
come parola innovat orio che è un ponte
tra l'italia e gli stati uniti per dare
ai ragazzi di talento di vero talento
quelle opportunità che mi sento di poter
dire forse a un'intera generazione di
musicisti e mancata almeno nel mio paese
e questa è una amena un tentativo di
fare questa cosa e quindi di dare la
possibilità oggettivamente di sognare
perché come dicevamo è la cosa più
importante
allora la cosa con cui vorrei salutarvi
ovviamente qualche nota dopo tante
parole ed è perché no ho pensato di
partire ritornare agli inizi e quindi mi
son era il primo brano la primissima
volta il primissimo brano che abbia mai
scritto quindi la primissima volta in
cui io sono uscito dalla mia comfort
zone e quindi mi sono avventurato come
potevo nell'ambito creativo compositivo
cercando di fare qualcosa in questo
senso quindi la primissima il primissimo
passo in questa direzione
e tra l'altro questo è un brano che
nasce esattamente dalla suggestione di
quel primissimo viaggio come musicista
di strada
[Musica]